hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update after going back and forth
for the past couple days about the
resolution from the console versions of
watchdogs Ubisoft just finally put the
matter to rest with a recent blog post
the blog post says quote on new gen
systems the game will run at 900p on ps4
and 792 p on xbox one at 30 frames per
second on both consoles watchdogs
creative director Jonathan Morin says
he's more concerned with the overall
experience rather than the technical and
minutiae he said you make choices about
the experience you want to deliver in
our case dynamism is everything
exploration and expression or everything
you want to have a steady framerate but
you want to have dynamism at the core of
the experience and the same goes with
resolution watchdogs was originally set
to release in November of 2013 but the
six-month delay wasn't spent optimizing
resolution Morin said he was more
interested in improving and polishing
the gameplay and making sure the players
can quote express themselves through
hacking that's important resolution has
nothing to do with that that's why stuff
like resolution can scale a bit down so
that we can never compromise the soul of
watchdogs overall it looks like the
watchdog developer is focusing on
gameplay over graphical minutiae and
hopefully that pays off in a more robust
experience when the game comes out and
the game is launching on May 27th be
sure to stay tuned to gamespot com for
full coverage